what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i played freshman ball and we're playing
pattison eastside
that's just the jungle of a school like
you got to be careful when you're going
there
and uh we went there to play the
christmas tournament
wait what kind of ball are we talking
right now oh basketball and i hadn't
taken this [__] for like ten days i
backed up something i took acid
something [__] my stomach but i didn't
tell nobody
in those days i was really scared of
doctors and i wouldn't say [__] to
nobody
on the way home we got on the bus
and while we were waiting there my
stomach started hurting
and i said jesus christ i don't know if
i'm gonna [__] myself a fart
well let me just take a chance and i
blew this fart joe rogan
that was so bad right we were on a bus
and people started running you know
school buses people started running to
the windows right
to swing down the bus windows but here's
where it gets better i fought it again
and the teachers were going oh my god
he's changing flavors
changing flavors but the worst thing was
the cheerleaders were crying that's how
bad it smelled
they were sitting in front of the bus
he's changing flames one of the teachers
yelled out
oh my god he's changing flavors that's
how bad these parts were
you were put in a position to defend
yourself
what would come out would it be the jiu
jitsu training or would it be the jersey
in you
the gun [__] i'm 53 i got time to hand
the hand wrestle i got a 22 in my
[__] right now
pointing straight there's there's been
um you know a lot of uh people that are
moving towards minimalist houses really
small houses
and you know the idea is that like
really why do we have to have this giant
[__] footprint of house that we live
in you know
because you're getting paid [__] if i
want to live in a [__] cell
i'll live in a [__] cell like a
monkey i'm going to live with a fold up
bed
like i'm james bond like if you're
getting paid you live in a [__] house
i'm going to live in a micro [__]
house with a little kitchen
to look like i got a black guy banging
me in the [__] ass i don't need that
a micro house what are you [__]
people talking about i just snapped out
of it though you can't take me into
those deep waters
the eureka [__] kill the brother
right now the [__] are these people
micro houses in the [__] desert
you play it after the world ends like a
doctor i want to live in one of those uh
the airstream
brian's down joey's not i think we have
a real clear line we're saying here
people
i [__] hate like if somebody calls me
and says hey call god forbid tom segura
his dad passed away i give it a day
i call him like i usually do tom i love
you
i'm sorry about your dad and then i'll
just drop like a
what are we getting in the will you know
what i'm saying is it going to your
[__] creepy sister
are we getting you know what do we and
people usually go
you [__] yeah thank you for
making me laugh
jesus christ nobody has the balls to
call
and insult me like i'll call people and
go you got a brother
what do you want do you want to light
him on fire so he gets nothing
nobody gets nothing nobody else can test
the will
and they'll die laughter like don't push
me because i hate that [__] as
it is
and for five minutes i just made that
day remember that time
you told me you mugged that gay guy and
he beat the [__] out of you yeah
he used to tie uh parachutes on his bags
of cocaine
so if the cops came and he threw him out
the window off the balcony
that this is this is how this is where
it takes your mind but anyway
that's a complete different story here i
am here i am with this 60 year old cuban
with under around nothing else and a gun
right and he's walking around he's doing
coke and now he starts crawling
and he's running running into a room and
he's doing blowing i'm sitting there
watching tv and i'll never forget the
song that was on you know what the hot
song was that week
checkercon checkercon
let me rocket checkercon let me and i
heard that
i heard that song over and over i stayed
with him
for four hours while he's doing the best
blown miami
and i'm sitting there like a [__]
priest drinking [__] soda
really eating sandwiches and i'm dying
inside i'm starting to do this blow
and in the middle of all this i hear the
gun goes off
and he shoots himself in the foot and
i'm like about to faint
from anxiety and debt and i
and this kid comes in and his wife and
they're like what happened i'm like he
shot himself he shot him to like
that's the third time in two years look
at his [__] foot
he shot himself in the ankle it was
[__] crazy and the cops came they
already knew ah what'd you do monaco you
shot yourself again jesus christ
when are you gonna stop doing that [__]
they [__] took it it was like another
day in miami and i'm like oh
my god now i don't have a ride now i'm
gonna take a [__] eighty dollar cab
ride
i gotta go smoke a second hold on a
minute very solid points
don't do the uh don't no i know joey you
get it i'm with you but
to let the american public know that
every four years they buy the same [__]
they've been buying every four
years and the same people with their
harvard articulation
and how they don't curse and they're
christians and they have a family and
these are the same people that shove it
up your [__]
ass every year the one thing that you
get about me is i'll say
[__] but i will not [__] rob you if i
need something i'll ask you like a man
hey hey go go [__] yourself you cop hold
on hold on one second make a joke
take a shuttle joey diaz facebook
twitter
check yourself before you wreck yourself
big dicks in your ass
all right get out of here you're in
trouble i'm the umpire
this is the i'm throwing all right all
right listen
stay black because that's the most
important uh okay okay
hey joe you killed michael jackson no no
i don't know look at the movie he was
dancing and singing
and next you know he's dying oxygen no
not am i right like junkies are junkies
and junkies a junkie every day
he doesn't wake up sing and dance and
then he has oxygen tanks at night
something's not right there
and in my case like old school you're
worth more dead than what you are alive
yeah
i mean he's worth more now than he's
ever been striking called
hardly kill michael what's changed where
they go on fox news they don't give a
[__] no more
because nobody said nothing they don't
give a [__]
why would they half of these kids are
coming back this is the worst
it doesn't matter if they're addicted
cussing is what's bad no you can't do
nothing to me that castro hasn't already
done
and when this [__] goes down isn't that
in scarface that's right and i gotta
re-quote that [__] right there i
flew in the flight afterwards
and i had [__] a bag i knew an
airport was coming with uh i had a
little bag of reefer in my [__]
no you didn't i do but this is a
conspiracy thing this is just to show
you
how hard the airport people are working
with that [__] x-ray machine
now i had it in a baggie and i put under
my left nut no okay we're not telling
this story
that's enough yes for freedom of speech
i'll call obama right now
they said we're going to put you to the
x-ray machine i'm standing there
sweating bullets
with this baggie under my [__] oh
that's an option because my left neck is
bigger than the right knee because i'm
alrighty stop people don't know that i
thought i had cancer for a couple weeks
you know the opposite hand is like in
the control
not to mention my balls i'm sweating now
because i'm gonna go to jail tonight
he's clear and he shook my hand and i'm
like my taxpayers are hard at work
hey so go [__] yourself you cop hold on
hold on one second pick a joke
take the shuttle joey diaz facebook
twitter
check yourself before you wreck yourself
big dicks in your
stay black because that's the most
important uh okay they have not found
osama bin laden
and he's in new york right now somebody
seen him last week in a hot dog stand
they know the energy concept of it
i am suffering so much inside
and i have so much anxiety inside i got
two options you unleash it
i could either go up there and go
or do my company
so how does my comedy come out like a
farm yellow i take that mic
wow i got a [__] i'm going soccer
there's no measuring with no you suck
him right in the mouth
you know oh he's he's he's measuring
they love it when the audience booze
that's when you know you're doing your
job i got i got
i'm at the comedy store i'm following
eight beasts and i got three bees behind
me
i told him the other day i don't go to
the comedy store to be the best comic i
go to the comedy store to be remembered
do you understand me i mean this was
nonstop another night bonehead came home
high on heroin
he decided to make french fries so he
put the pot out remember this
remember in the 80s they had those pots
you could bring it home with the hot oil
and they would boil and you could throw
french fries america went crazy over
them i forgot what they were
crazy french fry machine everybody was
making onion rings and [__]
well he did heroin and nodded up and
left the thing around the thing went on
fire
we're all in the [__] house oh jesus
all right i went into oil i wake up to
ba boom
and alarms and awesome kurt's waking me
up and we go out of the house and the
father's outside and the grandmother
and the fire department crawls on top of
the roof joe and they're hitting the
[__] roof
to let the smoke out and fire trucks are
coming from the side laying water and
they got the sirens
in the middle of all this it's hate in
the morning and we all look around and
go oh my god
emil's still in the house bonehead was
still in the house on fire
bro they turned the fire off they go in
he's still with his feet up
with his hands crossed just heroined out
of his mouth watching tv like nothing
happened
he slept through the fire oh my god
everything when they woke him up he goes
are my fries
ready this is how crazy this family was
all my fries ready we have two [__]
battalions out there
we got half of 9 11 oh my god
and you're still [__] sleeping hold
on let me go get a wine glass yeah just
give me the [__] glasses
i gotta wait thing this is pour the
[__] wine in there what's it
different
well the wine the aromatic listen shut
the [__] up before i smack you just give
me the [__] wine yeah
he would always come down with wine
glasses it would piss me
the [__] off to no end and the girls
would be impressed oh my god shut the
[__] up
drink the wine just shut the [__] up
drink the [__] wine you know
like i'm one of those guys i don't like
no drama and the people i grew up i
remember one time going to dinner with
my friends
i'll never forget this i still talked to
them the holloways
roger had just graduated high school the
craziest family i grew up with
yeah that was a bookie mom worked in the
city on the ship like uh for a shipping
company
and it's his 18th we just graduated high
school and he took us to a fancy
restaurant
and i'll never forget the guy comes over
with the thing in front of him yeah
mr holloway says can i get a bottle of
wine the guy comes over with a thing in
front of him
and he's you know takes the bottle and
he pours a little and he tastes it first
i'll never forget in high school in high
school
my friend looked again just give me the
[__] wine
the guy's face turned pale really i just
give it a one i don't want no show
yeah you don't have to taste it just
gonna take a [__] hike give me the
one
like we all froze at the table oh
like i grew up with people like that
like one time we were at a buffet
and some fat chick was eating ribs and i
kept looking at my friend roger
and he was eating but he kept looking at
it and he would look at it and he would
get mad he'd look at it finally
i saw him put the fork down and he threw
the napkin down he went up to the
chicken he goes let me ask you a
question
because he she kept eating all the spare
ribs
there was this place that gave you half
a spare rib and she was taking all of
them
and she was dipping her fat little
fingers in the sparabs and putting them
back and my friend like two weeks after
the incident with the [__] wine guy
yeah he went up to this chicken and goes
let me ask you a question
before you eat that wing before you eat
that rib
do me a favor go to the bathroom look at
your ass
and ask yourself do i really need this
rib
i'll never forget we turned purple yeah
the people i grew up with
were very like we don't like chick
chowder yeah there's no chick like my
wife she would have got killed
really my friends would have stabbed me
that's so funny terry
is a sweetheart yeah but she's so
someone that she likes to do chit chat
up
i'm deaf yeah don't teach your channel
if you got something to say say it don't
be chit chit-chattering yeah
i don't like that uh sitcom mentality
like little jokes
my friends would have killed her yeah my
friends would have stabbed her
they didn't like that either you get in
the car with them shut the [__] up what
worked to me is
you got to do something you don't meet
somebody they don't do nothing
you meet somebody they don't do nothing
don't do nothing
they don't date they don't do drugs they
don't play jackets
they don't do that how long do you like
those people for you don't
i like people a little bit edge to them
they got to do something
if you tell me i don't like alcoholics
but i love heroin i'm
in if you tell me you suck toes for
breakfast i mean
you gotta do something and he told us
about any [__]
uh in his backyard and somebody thought
it was a beard
i'd never forget delaney
she would let her dogs out every day and
then she would clean up they were all
french poodles
yeah yeah see the dogs is high up in the
air
we're just reeling back from the [__]
like shut up
this [__] joe rogan she looked at it and
she's like 58
so she's squinting at the [__] up
against the wall
i took a [__] and i put my back against
the wall
so when i [__] when you [__] outside
it's not going to be a decent [__]
yeah it's going to be like explosive so
when i got up it looks like somebody got
shot in the head
there was [__] all behind me on the wall
so she's sitting there with her little
french poodles
and her little chihuahuas and she's
looking at the wall like what the [__]
happened there
and all of a sudden she actually walks
up close to it
and squints and looks down on it and
looks around and runs in the house
i'm watching all this i can't breathe
and now i go to the computer because my
wife's very decent
i'm sitting there for a half hour and
then my wife comes in and she goes were
you home all day today
i go yeah why should i just had a
conversation with susan
[Laughter]
she wanted to know if you heard anything
in the backyard because some animals
took a [__] back there
i went i went to get sushi
like you ever go get sushi eat a lot of
it and yeah the rice pushes everything
out yes
yes and you had plans to go get a weed
store you want to go to the post office
but i made a detour i planned to go home
but i left the house key in the house
so i had to climb around the window
that's what happened yeah yeah so when i
pulled myself up
i actually landed with my stomach on the
window
and now you really made it push it out
more like
and i'm fatter than [__] and my hands
are struggling the window
and my little feet are on the other side
and the cats are meowing at me
scratching at me right
and i'm like it's me you [__]
so i ran out ran down the stairs oh [__]
outside
[Music]
get up everybody get up it's memorial
day weekend
i'm sure you had a grandpa who killed a
japanese person
[Music]
i'm sure you had an uncle who stabbed
the puerto rican in the heart
something get up it's not about potato
salads and cheeseburgers you [__]
it's about being a [__] american a
state of mind you need to be born in
america to be an american
you just need to get up in the morning
grab your balls and look at the flag
and look at jesus and say you know what
i got this [__] i don't need no
[__] welfare check
i'm a savage all i need is a [__]
knife a spear
and a f i don't even know what i need no
if it's two in the afternoon and you
ain't high go [__] yourself get out of
my face
i want you around me like you gotta
[__] go in new york yeah you gotta go
people don't go like this
stop sign yeah how they do here like
no you go what the [__] somebody [__]
go already
[__] [__] i gotta get to the weed
store when israelis come to the store
you better be prepared they [__] come
heavy duty to the store i've been up
there a couple tuesdays and three of
them are stuck up on me
we're from israel where's the flying jew
we want our position
where's the stars of dad they're [__]
nuts and you gotta love them
you gotta love me at the comics from
listening to rogan experience
they started doing comedy i guess
israel's got a big comedy
scene there's starting now she's
starting and they [__] want to be
rough comics so the one kid's like i'm
trying to do [__] hitler jokes
and they're throwing and they're
throwing me out of all these places
i'm [__] out i'm a holland people
like what is he talking about
he's like i'm doing fun of these dirty
hitler jokes and that israeli people
throwing me out of restaurants and [__]
because i'm coming to america
these [__] i'm sitting there
going oh no
where's the flying jew we want to meet
up
i'm coming to america to do hitler's
show oh my god he was pissed this kid he
was doing
he was serious he's like dog my
colleague's a little rough
he goes i'm up there doing [__] nazi
[Music]
jokes